le procès d'un crime raciste la cour
d'assises de paris va juger à partir de
demain le meurtre d'un jeune marocain
dans le box
quatre skinheads qui participait à une
manifestation du front national à faire
que nous rappelle valérie war carole
gaessler et jacques gauthier une gerbe
de fleurs jeter dans l'eau de la seine
chaque 1er mai les associations
antiracistes se souviennent de la mort
de brahim morale 1er mai 95 le jeune
marocain flâne au bord de l'eau sur le
fond du carrousel le front national
défilent trois jeunes skinheads s'écarte
du cortège et rejoignent le quai l'un
d'eux michael frais mines et pousse
brahim bouarram dans le fleuve
les pompiers trouveront son corps un peu
plus loin sans se retourner les trois
skins rejoignent la manifestation sans
être vraiment militants du front
national michael fréminet dira aux
policiers qu'il n'avait rien contre ce
parti se défiler c'était aussi
l'occasion de faire la fête entre
copains
après son service militaire chez les
parachutistes parmi ses amis un axe
adhérents du front national déjà connu
pour des agressions
la bande avait profité du car gratuit
mis à la disposition des manifestants
phare le front national un parti qui
porte une responsabilité morale dans ce
drame selon la partie civile en aucune
manière séparée l'acte commis
parce là d'une certaine forme de pensée
développée par le front national qui ne
peut une manière ou d'une autre qu'elle
est dans le même sens pendant quatre des
témoins décrivent le manège d'un groupe
de skinheads insultant des étrangers un
manifestant du front national parle d'un
acte violent et volontaire michael frais
menée par le lui d'un accident une gifle
malheureuse qui aurait fait trébucher le
marocain la victime
loredana sultan interpellé chez ses
parents près de reims il offre l'image
d'un jeune désoeuvré totalement immature
skinheads pour la frime mais pas pour
les idées mais qu'elle est très minée
d'abord n'a aucune conscience politique
ensuite il n'est pas lui-même et
skinhead
il n'appartenait pas un groupe de
skinheads il était habillé avec
effectivement ce jour là un bon beurre
saint jean des chaussures des chaussures
noires qui s'apparente à celle des skins
et il avait les cheveux très courts
parce qu'il sortait juste de son service
militaire
nickel fréminet risque aujourd'hui 30
ans de réclusion criminelle à retenir
dans le reste de l'action